c'est une étape de plus pour le métro du
grand paris express les premiers travaux
ont commencé sur plusieurs tronçons
franciliens c'est le cas notamment pour
les futures lignes à 15 et 16 pour la
ligne 18 en revanche qui desservira
saint quentin en yvelines elle les
études techniques sont encore en cours à
ce stade là il n'y a pas de retard
puisque on en était vraiment aux études
préliminaires
maintenant le maître d'oeuvre a été
désigné et donc il va travailler sur les
études d'avant projet et c'est à ce
niveau des études d'avant projet qu'on
fixe définitivement le tracé de la ligne
est la position des gardes
à terme la ligne 18 du grand paris
express reliera l'aéroport d'orly à
versailles coût du projet estimé à un
peu moins de 3 milliards d'euros pour
une mise en service totale en 2030 d'ici
là plusieurs projets pensés par des
étudiants franciliens verront le jour
l'un d'entre eux doit favoriser les
échanges entre riverains commerçants et
entreprises avec comme espace d'accueil
des containers ça sera vraiment c'est
l'impact visuel qu'on veut d'abord à
voir donc avec le conteneur sera
vraiment la forme à de la tôle quoi avec
une terrasse qu'on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude de voir sur un camp tonnerre
et l'intérieur par contre sera vraiment
aménagé pour par exemple pour la
restauration avec vraiment les
réfrigérateurs le plan de travail donc
l'intérieur sera vraiment
nouveau pour le consommateur
utilisateurs et consommateurs devront en
tout cas se montrer patient les
premières rames de métro dans les
yvelines n'arriveront pas avant 14 ans